while there are some alessoma species
that reproduce sexually most reproduce
asexually dividing to form a copy of
itself the Ala Soma creates its clone at
its end linking the old and new versions
of itself like a chain you can see the
new Ayla Soma here looking like it's
attached to the other's butt because
it's attached to the others butt and
this chain can keep going as the aeola
Soma keeps dividing adding more worms
that are connected together so that the
final length of their combined bodies
sometimes reaches around 10 millimeters
total that's 10 millimeters of clones
combined to create one giant mega worm
until eventually the chain breaks and
they all go their separate ways